aux États-Unis en Inde et en Chine on se
réfugie à l'ombre ou au frais le plus
possible c'est que la planète n'a jamais
été aussi chaude deux jours de suite la
température moyenne de l'air à la
surface du globe à fracasser le record
datant de 2016 cette canicule touche
également le Canada ou des
avertissements de chaleur ont été mis un
peu partout notamment dans le Grand Nord
au Québec coup de joueur râpique écoute
joue à condépasser la barre des 34
degrés Celsius battant ainsi des records
vieux de 61 ans à Val-d'Or et à Radisson
également les records sont tombés la
balle citoyens souffre dans leurs
habitations plutôt conçues pour les
grands froids
qui datent des années 70 et c'est l'été
là lorsque le soleil plombe dessus qu'on
a des vagues de chaleur c'est comme un
faux c'est extrêmement difficile et pour
les personnes qui sont plus âgées c'est
encore plus difficile le Premier
ministre canadien s'inquiète de la fonte
du père Gilson là-bas ça va contribuer
non seulement à de la déstabilisation de
communauté dans le Nord mais le méthane
qui est en est sorti est très puissant
comme émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
et donc nous nous devons de ralentir le
réchauffement de la planète nous devons
faire tout ce qu'on peut pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques et
cette année le phénomène Elio accentue
déjà ces perturbations mais clairement
alignons à un effet aussi majeur sur
l'amplification du réchauffement voire
même exacerber certaines vagues de
chaleur qui peuvent se produire
d'ailleurs ici en Amérique du Nord ou
ailleurs en Europe ou à travers le monde
et est-ce qu'on doit s'en inquiéter
simplement par le réchauffement
climatique oui mais aussi par l'impact
qu'un juste ce mois-ci donc l'intensité
des feux de forêts dans le Nord qui est
vraiment est influencé par ces
chaleurs-là présentement pour régénérer
d'autres feux de forêt agréable la
situation les experts s'entendent les
vagues de chaleur seront plus intenses
et plus longues il était ne fait que
commencer ici Audrey neveu Radio-Canada
Montréal